armé de son cv et de son plus beau
sourire fiona tan de sa chance avec
cette entreprise basée à maurepas
cela fait plusieurs mois qu'elle cherche
du travail dans les services à la
personne
moi c'est plus dans le ménage repassage
à la personne alors je m'oriente vers
plus sur ces stands là pour trouver plus
facilement les cv lettre de motivation
il me recontacter possible s'il ya une
place j'ai énormément besoin de salariés
ça fait un an que j'existe je me suis
j'ai créé ma société donc l'an dernier
en 2016 je suis aujourd'hui à 10
salariés et je suis en perpétuelle
recrutement pour ni plus moins répondre
aux besoins de les clients qui sont des
clients réguliers sur lequel intervient
chaque semaine pour effectuer des
prestations de ménage de garde d'enfants
et de manière ponctuelle du jardinage du
bricolage
une quarantaine d'entreprises ont
répondu à l'appel lancé par la ville de
coignières pour participer à cette 15e
journée de recrutement
un rendez vous incontournable pour tous
les secteurs de la pâtisserie au digital
ont fait une vingtaine de recrutements
par an à peu près ce sont des
développeurs web des ingénieurs sécurité
médiateur de projet des ingénieurs
sharks donc vraiment sur les métiers de
la haute technologie
on a beaucoup de besoins au niveau de
nos clients en gros tu allais cetera
autres et on a du mal à trouver
effectivement les candidats c'est un
forum de recrutement qui permet à de
nombreuses personnes bien sûr du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
mais également des communes et des
départements limitrophes même parce que
nous avons les personnes d'eure-et-loir
de l'essonne
qu'ils viennent effectivement dans ce
salon échange de cv prise de contact qui
aboutisse très souvent un entretien
cette année encore environ 900 candidats
ont fait le déplacement